we're 18 months away and the Republicans
already have their guy the dams they're
narrowing their choices down from what a
Republican operative called
one big socialist organism with 22 heads
which assumes some of these people
actually have heads the Democratic Party
response every time we try to help the
underdog you call it socialism when
actually socialism is all about creating
underdogs the Dems have all the ends and
none of the means promising lots of toys
from Santa without ever trying to build
a workshop which is why at the end of
every false promise it's always soak the
rich until there are no rich people left
except their rich friends of course
and it never works because even in a
free market you can't bankroll a
left-wing money pit Venezuela was rich
once upon a time but will this next
election be another clash between the
ours and the DS or not panic hasn't it
the Dems yet because they haven't
learned a damn thing from 2016 the
lessons are clear the healthiest widest
swath of America hates politicians and
the media who selects them it's a
healthy perspective for it opens the
door to candidates you don't fit into
boxes or change their accent or fake
phony Cadence's the Dems when you think
about it could use one of these I have
to tell you that runway is like an ice
skating rink and the first step I said
you know this sucker is slippery I think
it was put in by the Democrats that's a
trap I'm telling you it's like it's like
ridiculous can you imagine if I went
down the press would have a field day
for weeks and winners as I stand here
floating around on a piece of ice this
is crazy this is the worst damn stage I
stupid people did this one no no or
brilliant all right laugh all you want
but that's a political phenomenon born
from exhaustion people got sick of the
game so if the old politician was the
bubblegum rock of the 1970s Trump was
the punk rocker who cleared the field
will the Dems find their own Ramon their
own Johnny Rotten don't ask the Dems
they haven't the slightest clue we have
lots of fun stuff lots of tape today and
the best
please bado on the view we have to talk
about that you have to talk let's go to
that thing
and with more because you're a man
you're right there are things that I
have been privileged to do in my life
that that others cannot would you say
those are mistakes be on the cover of
Vanity Fair yeah so maybe it's the lead
us what what yeah yeah I think it
reinforces that that perception of
privileged data there is probably
nothing less attractive than that I
think that Biden's entry into the race
that's really scrambled the whole thing
right now you have all of these
superstars or like superstars for a
couple of weeks at least saying okay
wait now I'm way down in the polls
they're not getting any traction blossom
staffers reconvened started reboot
revamp and he goes on there and I kind
of liked it when he was arrogant guy on
the thing waving his arms around like
standing on tables and that was a lot
more appealing than agreeing that he
looks small he looks small she had taken
something away from him yes I think they
removed something around his neck I
don't understand who he's trying to
appeal to with that answer because well
maybe it's the view audience I don't
know but I kind of liked it when he was
being himself and now he feels over
managed yes yes it reinforces this idea
that politicians will say whatever they
have to depending on the audience yeah
if it was for the view audience that's
not the audience is gonna get you votes
in the early states that you need to get
up in the polls
that is so it's so inauthentic and he
was supposed to be authentic cool guy
yes skateboard and everything he's done
so far is completely phony it's the it's
that you know okay with the experiment
would he put Trump in that seat yeah can
get him to change his position what do
you think China's gonna do right is
gonna say take that back bado and I'll
say okay you mean black China or trying
to Philips trying to the country oh okay
just want to make sure about the view
you know I think in fact when he said
that he is speaking to the view audience
and he's speaking about there was
criticism as I recall from Colonel
Harris and others and said oh look this
guy shows up and he gets on the cover of
was the Vanity Fair yes because all of a
sudden he's the flavor of the day he
looks he's so handsome he looks like
Kennedy yeah but you know but then
what's really held him down you notice
his numbers have not gone up and I think
part of it is people started to see him
as the rich kid who had a car accident
left the scene and all the rest like a
Kennedy and the kid who has not only
lots of money but his wife is a
zillionaire apparently and so I think
this has changed the perceptual I think
he is speaking to American women when he
says yeah I understand that being a man
comes with certain benefits especially
in the world of politics you don't hear
people complaining about his voice
recently done something pretty
incredible right he had raised lots of
millions of dollars not necessarily all
from Texas gave Ted Cruz a run for his
money I mean obviously Ted Cruz beat him
handily but he actually had done
something so one of the reasons it gets
on Vanity Fair cover is because he's
willing to do it and if you want to have
a good press like that you want to be on
the cover of Vanity Fair well let Vanity
Fair write around with you like you did
that was it wasn't all glowing that but
Vanity Fair it would embrace him they
don't like Vanity Fair would do that
kind of thing with a conservative Kamala
Harris well I think more magazines than
Kamala Harris maybe this guy's dreamy
he's got the shirt dreams the same shirt
every single shot and this was supposed
to be the new Kennedy and that's what
they were trying to propel him into and
obviously it fizzled out well what about
okay what about Kirsten Gillibrand okay
she's blaming her low poll numbers her
failing campaign on gender bias Wow but
she's calling the Democratic voter
sexist because something Republicans
that are paying attention to her she's a
below 3% so she's just calling the Dems
a bunch of well that's why the Trump
campaign has so much leverage when it
comes to the primary with all of these
candidates eating each other alive
because they don't have to do any of
this work in terms of what they're
saying and making non arguments the
reason why Kirsten Gillibrand is at the
bottom goes back to the inauthentic
thing again if you look at the policy
position she's put forward
in terms of the questions she's been
asked of town halls or in her her videos
where she's lifting weights and doing
all these things that are trying so hard
playing beer pong instead of just being
an authentic and not changing her
position she used to be for ice she's
now against ice she used to be pro NRA
she's now anti NRA and she hasn't been
able to explain why in a coherent way
that doesn't look like pandering she has
changed her policy positions and such an
extreme that I think she hasn't
developed a clear message I don't know
what the message is from her campaign I
can pick the others but I can't pick her
I will say that to get back to the top
of this segment when we were talking
about socialism I just find it so
striking that they say oh yeah it's the
Democrats are all socialists I'm
thinking really who are you saying camel
Harris is a social as well she just says
she wanted to know Roy private healthy
you know hang on that's not associates
to say we need to talk about how to
deliver quality health care to more
American an illegal immigrant is not a
socialist Joba some of this positions
are social it seems to me this is an
opportunity for it's an effort by people
in the Trump campaign to get away from
talking about real ideas for real
solutions and it's a get away from
Trump's fail promises on the wall on
health care on infrastructure oh no Dan
is rolling her eyes go for it
I was breathing deeply what is the deal
of politics you try to define your
opponent early the Democrats have tried
to define President Trump from the very
beginning for all of the things like you
could list them insane not stable
campaign just happens to be doing that
now to the Democrats and they left
themselves open for this criticism what
is not true if you support the green New
Deal and confiscating people's private
health insurance and giving its
government gun confiscation raising
taxes boosting spending those types of
things are socialist policy decision
disagree how they're selling it policy
here is hears that we are on a day when
Trump has said oh yeah I was going to
get you a deal with China do we have a
deal I'm wondering no tariffs we had a
lot of those can you define the
difference between a democratic
socialist and a socialist a socialist a
Lissa's state-owned means of production
my friend